hey 42 here the world can be a confusing
place sometimes so often many of us try
to make sense of it with our own little
routines and rituals like always putting
on your right shoe first or locking the
door three times just to make sure you
didn't forget but the amazing thing is
how often these little habits and ideas
become a full-blown superstition some of
which can last for centuries so cross
your fingers don't step on the cracks
throw some salt over your shoulder and
let's go look at some superstitions from
around the world let's start in Asia the
first thing that jumps out is numbers in
China eight is considered lucky since it
sounds like their word for prosperity
they really try to get the most out of
it for the Olympics in Beijing by
starting the opening ceremony at eight
seconds and eight minutes past 8 p.m. on
the 8th of August 2008 by a strange
coincidence in Japan it also has the
meaning of growing prosperous but this
is because a character for the number-8
broadens gradually by that logic in
English eight would mean you're going to
become a snowman
but cut that eight in half and you have
the horrible number for most of eastern
Asia is tetra phobic meaning they are
scared of four due to its similarity to
the word for death this is extremely
widespread and you're unlikely to find
buildings with a fourth floor good sold
in four packs or any parking lots with
that digit even numbers like 14 on 24 or
110 their 40s are avoided excluding 42
of course I may have just lost China
it's so severe in fact that giving
something to a fellow Asian with the
number 4 in it can be enough for the
police to get involved since it's seen
as a death threat so if you're ever
thinking about buying property there
guess which house is going to give you
the sweetest deal India has an aversion
to rounded numbers such as 100 or 70 and
prices are normally taken up by one
rupee
to avoid them a smart bit of business
Indians also like to feed milk to snakes
usually as a religious offering snakes
don't actually drink milk so thousands
die every year due to this practice so
don't feed snakes milk also in Korea
don't feed your boyfriend chicken wings
as it's a sign that he will fly away and
leave you whereas in the West if your
partner Fiji chicken wings is usually
seen as a sign that they're a keeper if
you're eating in Japan however don't
leave your chopsticks stuck in the rice
as this is reserved for funerals
instead you should rest them
horizontally across the bowl if you are
at a funeral
remember to hide your thumbs or the
recently departed will sneak under your
nails and cause your loved ones to die
young that's if they haven't already
been killed by leaving a fun on whilst
they sleep fun death is a very prevalent
fear in South Korea and all fans are
sold with a life-saving cutoff timer to
prevent you from being either
asphyxiated frozen or boiled to death
depending on which bit if
air-conditioning logic you apply no one
knows how it all started but there is an
excellent conspiracy theory that the
government made it up
during the 1970s energy crisis it will
be like combating the California drought
by telling everyone that having a bath
makes you fat the Middle East has some
of the oldest culture that exists today
so they have a rich tapestry of myths
and legends one very common one is the
evil eye
this is a curse that can bring great
misfortune to a person giving them bad
luck an unhappy life or perhaps just a
bad dinner or no phone reception in very
mild cases the evil I can get you at any
time cast by a hate-filled glare without
your knowing so how do you protect
yourself on this terror what you need is
another an I shaped amulet typically a
blue colored crystal that can be worn
around your neck hung above your door or
lost on the back of your sofa for none
amulet
based protection you can also use the
phrase mashallah which expresses
appreciation and you can try to dress
yourself humbly to avoid the eyes
vicious gaze there is a universal
protection against all malicious spirits
in the Middle East not just I based ones
called the casma and it's just an image
of an open right palm occasionally
precious possession such as cars are
anointed with right hand prints to make
sure they're protected
there are many superstitions based
around creepy crawlies in Qatar it was
once believed that spiders have the
ability to control house fires so if you
killed one it was like murdering a tiny
firefighter the spiders were no help at
getting cats as the trees though so
fortunately they kept the fire
department up and running also beetles
were a sign that guests are coming and
you should prepare for their arrival
welcoming guests and people in need into
your home is actually a big part of
Islamic culture but they must be careful
with their feet and not just to avoid
crushing your eight-legged firemen a new
home must be entered with the right foot
first but a bathroom must be entered
with the left foot it's the household
hokey-cokey in some areas of Africa
superstitions carry a lot of weight and
are a big part of daily life especially
when it comes to things like sickness
and success many villages across a
continent have a witch doctor who will
be consulted before consulting a medical
professional some of the cures that are
suggested by these witch doctors involve
the patient acquiring ingredients such
as the eggs of a snake or the claws of a
wild cat I imagine it reduces the amount
of people calling in sick for work
imagine if you needed to go get some
alligator teeth in order to be written a
sick note um no thanks I'll be at my
desk in Sierra Leone Alhaji Suleiman
Kaba runs the union of traditional
healers and one major area of concern
for them are which guns these aren't
pointy hazard women holding firearms
like you might be thinking but a way
you've kill
with a curse according to Kaaba the
earliest and deadliest type of witch gun
is made out of the husk from rice so
beware anyone carrying a bag of basmati
for the airport check-in although you
don't need to be on the plane to do the
damage since the range of these guns is
unlimited and although witchcraft is not
officially recognized in the cause
suspects have still been tried and
convicted for these suspicious killings
nevertheless anyone who dies young
without an obvious cause is often
thought to be the victim of a witch gun
attack and if you can't find a witch is
gone then grab her broomstick since in
Nigeria it's thought that hitting a man
with a broom can cause him to become
impotent even making his entire genitals
disappear
fortunately the victim can quickly save
himself if he grabs the broom and
returns at least 7 blows to his attacker
I don't even want to think about what
happens if you hit someone with a vacuum
cleaner
speaking of manhood in order to reach it
within the Maasai tribe in Kenya the
young boy must head out to the plains
and catch himself a lion using only a
spear we come to Europe now and we'll
start with one of the favorite pastimes
drinking from Russian vodka to German
beer and French wine the Europeans love
to drink a report from the World Health
Organization published in 2014 showed
Belarus leading the world in alcohol
consumption per capita with 17.5 liters
of alcohol drunk per person per year now
just to be clear that's pure booze so in
more realistic terms that would be
equivalent to about 900 pints of beer
per person per year in fact European
countries occupied 26 of the top 30
alcohol consuming nations with only
Grenada South Korea Australia and South
Africa joining in for another round at
the winners
so given europe's love of the bottle
there are plenty of alcoholic
superstitions going around in russia you
should always finish all of your drink
and if it's a shot
you must never put it back on the table
until it is empty you should click
glasses for each new round of drinks
unless you're at a Funeral
if you want to send your friends to
their funeral in Germany you just have
to say Cheers
or crossed in German with a glass of
water it's considered very rude in
places like Bavaria since you are
wishing death upon everyone but the
Germans often meet up for a drink down
their local often called a Standish
meaning regulars table when you walk in
rather than waving to the group you
should knock on the oak table that they
are all sitting around now as you all
know the devil can't torch oak he has
some sort of allergy I believe so to
prove you are not the devil
you should rap on the table in France if
you are drinking you are very likely to
be eating as well they have the generic
fear of the number 13 like much of
Europe and the US but it's especially
true for a dinner party
13 guests will mean things will turn out
very badly for one unlucky diner this is
for to come from Jesus's Last Supper
where Judas turned out to be a traitor
any bread on the table should always be
the right way off since upside-down
bread is the bread for the hangman you
see in olden France the bakers didn't
want to serve the hangman but the king
warned them that it was either that or
they would end up as toast themselves so
they picked out the worst bread and
turned it upside down in disdain for
their least popular customers in Denmark
if your dinner party gets drunk and
disorderly and you end up breaking all
the crockery not to worry just scrape it
up and save it for the end of December
on New Year's Eve take all your smashed
plates and cups and chuck them at your
friend's house as a way to break in the
New Year according to the Danes the more
you Pelt them with
the better their next 12 months will be
South America has the world's largest
jungle and River the Amazon and as you
can imagine in a place with such a wild
abundance of life the plants and animals
have given rise to a huge amount of
different stories and beliefs in Brazil
the river dolphins or boto have a
mystical place in society anyone lost
amongst the trees is fought to have been
taken into the water and turned into a
dolphin they can't turn back into a
human but they can sneak up on to the
land wearing catfish for shoes and
stingrays for hearts and impregnates
the local women in Argentina no one
turns into a dolphin but if you are
foolish and fertile enough to have a
seventh son beware he will turn into a
werewolf and it won't be every full moon
that he changes rather every Tuesday and
Friday specifically so he'll never be
able to join that yoga class if you want
to own werewolf him you'll need to get
the President to adopt him I'm not even
joking one president who will be of no
help though is Carlos Menem the
Argentine leader throughout the 90s his
name is now a curse so avoid saying it
in public in Venezuela is two Jaguars
that are bad look and you must kill any
that you see looking around the village
for good look though many South
Americans have a great way of wishing in
the new year
the key is yellow underwear nothing like
a little splash of color to get you
going for the next six months
however in Chile beware of the splash
for if a woman gets her dress wet while
she is washing the clothes she will end
up with a drunk husband now the u.s. in
particular given its history is really a
melting pot of superstitions from all
around the world so there are some
obvious ones that we all know about but
do you know how they came about many
people have paraskevi paraskevi deep
they have this it's a fear of Friday the
fur team now it's quite a new
superstition but certainly older than
Sean s Cunningham movie from the 1980 it
probably been around for a couple of
hundred years and it's just a
combination of a long-held distrust of
the number thirteen and the fact that
Friday is the day that Jesus was
crucified so not his best day many
superstitions such as this one starts
small was spread through a psychological
reaction called the baader-meinhof
phenomenon sometimes called frequency
illusion say you meet someone at a party
and they tell you about this old bands
that they love which you've never heard
of let's call em SuperDrive for example
then the next day you're on a train
possibly hungover Frank to the party and
you see a guy wearing a t-shirt with
SuperDrive written on it it's the
universe speaking to you is this all an
illusion and you're the star of your own
Truman Show ah SuperDrive investing in a
crazy marketing promotion or just a
glitch in the matrix perhaps no it's
none of this the world is full of a vast
unimaginable amount of data you can
barely process a tiny fraction of it but
what your brain does do incredibly well
is spot patterns and connections that's
why you can recognize faces from
different angles and read words that are
spelt incorrectly so when you have some
new information your brain keeps an eye
out for anything related to it if you'd
seen that t-shirt a day before or a week
or two afterwards you wouldn't have even
noticed it you only noticed it because
your friends had told you about the band
the day before so how does this relate
to superstition well once you think
something is unlucky like a certain date
you will immediately remember anything
bad that happens to you and associate it
with that day so if your date cancels on
you on Friday the 13th it's all the
calendars fault but if you spill coffee
on yourself on Saturday 14th it's
because you're a badly coordinated [ __ ]
like Friday the 13th crossing your
fingers is also Christian in origin
since anything with the shape of the
cross was considered a good thing and in
fact it could have started in a
different form very early on in the
history of Christianity now back in the
day around the time of the Roman Empire
Christians were not exactly everyone's
favorite and they would often be sent
off as a snack for the Lions so in order
to identify a fellow Christian there is
a kind of secret handshake that involved
forming a cross with another's
outstretched finger and finally probably
one of the most common superstitions
around the world is that breaking a
mirror will bring you bad luck this
brings from the time of the Romans who
were the first people to create glass
mirrors it was thought that your
reflection contained a little piece of
your soul so of the mirror of brown not
only was your soul disfigured but it was
also trapped in a shiny cage the
association with seven years of bad luck
is due to the Roman idea that your body
renews itself every seven years so you
had to wait it out till you grew whole
again we all have our own ways of making
sense of the world and there's nothing
wrong with the art of ritual or
superstition to get you through the day
but if you can't leave the house without
wearing your lucky pants carrying a
horseshoe and a rabbit's foot I'm
breaking a whisper in every seven
minutes then I'm afraid bad luck has
already struck because you're clearly
mental thanks to the view subscribe for
more 42